fireworks in the courtroom Donald Trump
finally testified in open court and it
did not go well in just one incident in
the New York attorney general's $250
million civil fraud case Trump
repeatedly pulled out a piece of paper
out of a suit jacket sparking conflict
with judge Arthur Enron and when Trump
asked Enron if he quote would like to
see it the judge reacted like any
sensible person who has just been asked
if he wanted to see what a man is
keeping in his pocket I don't need to
see that but the order deal says never
take no for an answer so nevertheless
Trump persisted he said quote I would
love to read this your honor if I could
am I allowed to do that the judge was
irritated telling Trump again no not at
this point but Trump insisted that the
paper would completely clear his name
what was this mysterious piece of paper
well Trump believes that he can win the
Civil Trial with one weird trick a
disclaimer clause on his financial
statements and he said quote I think
that the statements of financial
conditions were very good were actually
somewhat conservative and they were
totally protected and so am I by the
disclaimer Clause but the thing is
before trial judge angron had already
ruled that the disclaimer doesn't
insulate Trump from his friend fraud
claims so the judge told Trump to quote
read my opinion again or for the first
time perhaps and Trump professed to be
shocked by the judge's refusal to read
the piece of paper quote he called me a
fraud and he didn't know anything about
me but the thing is judges get to decide
matters of law before the trial even
starts and the judge had already decided
that the disclaimer wasn't a valid legal
defense but yeah Trump really was losing
control and really was yelling and
pointing at the judge while on the
witness stand uh he continued quote the
fraud is on the court not on me the
fraud is on her here Trump was referring
to tis James quote I think she is a
political hack she used this case to try
to become governor this is a disgrace
all you have to do is read the legal
papers and the scholars this is a
political Witch Hunt and I think you
should all be ashamed of yourself now it
should probably not surprise you to
learn that generally Witnesses don't get
to introduce things into evidence by
pulling objects out of their sweaty
underclothes and the financial
statements at issue here which all
contain the disclaimer had already been
admitted into evidence but Trump was
determined to have some kind of Perry
Mason moment and this led to some
intense moments between him and the
judge and this was just one of the
insane things that happened when Donald
Trump took the stand in the New York
attorney general civil fraud trial and
the trial isn't even over yet but a lot
has happened so let's talk about what
happened when Trump took the stand now
through all this Trump has requested
that his trials be televised and I hate
to say it but I really agree with the
former president on this point some
people claim it would be good for Trump
some people claim it would be good for
prosecutors but either way this is of
national importance and it really seems
like the public has a right to know
sadly here this trial is not televised
so unfortunately we have to rely on
secondhand accounts uh but there were a
lot of people taking seemingly very good
notes during this whole thing now as you
may recall this trial stems from a civil
lawsuit filed by the New York attorney
general Laticia James the lawsuit
accuses Trump John Jr Eric the Trump
organization and several company
Executives of inflating the value of the
Trump organization's assets and Trump's
personal wealth to obtain better terms
on loans and insurance uh the New York
attorney general wants to recoup 250
million and limit the Trump's ability to
do business in New York and before the
trial judge Arthur Enron already ruled
that Trump committed financial fraud by
oversetting the value of his assets and
he canel the New York business
certificates of several of trump
businesses uh that order is stayed
pending appeal now the current trial
will resolve the other fraud claims and
determine what penalties the trumps must
pay during the trial Trump has
continually accused judge angeron of
pursuing him for political reasons and
after he shared a social media post
attacking the judge's principal law
Clerk judge angron issued a limited gag
order now Trump violated that order
twice and judge angron has fined him
$5,000 and then $10,000 and because of
this conduct Trump was forced to take
the stand for the first time to defend
the references that he was making in the
media where he claimed that the witness
that he was referring to was Michael
Cohen not the judge's clerk but judge
anron all but called Trump a liar he
said quote as a trior of fact I find
this testimony Rings Hollow and untrue
the Oxford English Dictionary defines
alongside as close to the side of next
to so yeah probably not how you want
your first testimony in that Court to go
but the judge's gag order initially only
applied to Trump but then Trump's
lawyers Christopher kais and Alina habba
started criticizing the clerk during
trial they argued that she was passing
the judge notes and that this was
evidence of anti-trump bias uh clerks uh
communicate with their judges that's a
perfectly acceptable practice as I'm
sure kais and habba surely know judge
anron then extended the gag order to
limit kais and habba and that too is now
on appeal but things went equally poorly
when Trump took the stand in the case in
Chief uh when Trump took the stand he
clashed with the judge immediately
giving long- winded answers and serving
a political monologues kais told the
judge that Trump's decades as a real
estate developer gave his opinion extra
weight quote if my choices were Donald
Trump or Attorney General James
respectfully I would go with Donald
Trump kais urged the judge to give Trump
who he described as The Once and Future
president leeway to answer questions the
way that he wanted to quote with this
witness I would suggest it's far more
efficient to to listen to what he has to
say and take it in but that comment
struck a nerve with judge angeron and he
said quote no I'm not here to hear what
he has to say I'm here to hear him
answer questions sit down judge andron
said he was considering drawing negative
conclusions from Trump's testimony quote
we got another speech I beseech you to
control him if you can if you can't I
will I will excuse him and draw every
negative inference that I can now
remember this is a bench trial so Enron
is acting as the Trier of fact who will
decide what really happened here there's
no jury famously because it seems that
Trump's lawyers uh did not request a
jury or check the box uh that would have
created a jury in this situation it's
actually incredibly normal for a judge
to be the tri or a fact instead of a
jury it happens all the time especially
in business related matters uh but here
I think it was clear that Trump's team
wanted a jury and just forgot to check
the box but later on in the questioning
Trump was especially triggered by
questions about maralago the Florida
golf club where he resides for most of
the year and gr's pre-trial ruling
finding Trump liable for fraud noted
that the local assessor valued marago at
18 million while in documents Trump
valued it at hundreds of millions more
now obviously the assessor's opinion was
only one and was not dis positive but
Trump certainly didn't back down and
went the other direction insisting that
he believes the club is worth as much as
1.5 billion now the attorney general has
argued that maralago would never be
valued that high because the property is
deed restricted and cannot be used as a
residence or be developed and Trump said
that he agreed to the deed restriction
for tax purposes he admitted that the
lower test value limits the property's
tax burden quote there are a lot of
advantages to the club status the
smartest thing to do would be to have a
club and have one member now as you can
probably tell Trump is going to need a
good lawyer on appeal to help him with
his terrible testimony but if you want a
great lawyer my firm the eagle team can
help if you've had an injury or death in
the family suffered a data breach or
were involved in a car crash we can
represent you or help find you the right
attorney who can just click on the link
in the description for free consultation
with my team because you don't just need
a legal team you need the eagle team so
the link is down below now this isn't
the worst argument in the world arguing
that a clause that the court has already
ruled several times doesn't say what you
say it says is the worst argument but
it's still not very good because in 1985
Trump purchased marago from the post
foundation and used the estate as a
private residence until 1995 Trump faced
hostility from Palm Beach residents who
blocked his attempt to subdivide the
property into multiple housing lots so
in April of 1995 the estate became a
private club Trump signed an agreement
with the city Banning club members from
spending more than 21 days a year at the
club's guest Suites Trump also granted
conservation easements to the National
Trust for historic preservation and in
2002 hoping to reduce his tax bill Trump
granted a new development easement to
the historic preservation trust it quote
limits changes to the property including
without limitation division or
subdivision of marlago for any purpose
including use as single family homes the
interior renovation of the Mansion which
may be necessary and desirable for sale
of the property as a single family
residential Suite the construction of
new buildings and the obstruction of
open Vistas the deed says quote the club
and Trump intend to Forever extinguish
their right to develop or use the
property for any purpose other than Club
use and according to Trump the deed
language is not legally binding he said
intend does not mean we will do it uh if
someone wanted to change it later I
believe they would have the right to do
it but Trump stopped short of saying he
believe the property could be developed
into a private residence quote if
somebody wanted it the smartest thing to
do have a club and have one member and
that would be the member who lives in
the club but it's much more valuable and
we'll show that in two weeks or five
weeks or nine weeks or whenever this
thing goes that its biggest value is in
using it as a club and although
conservation easements in Florida are
said to be Perpetual they can be amended
or released by agreement with the
easement holder uh the National Historic
preservation trust has agreed to amend
conservation easements to allow
development in the past however
releasing an easement is controversial
and is not guaranteed the property sits
on 17 Acres between the Atlantic Ocean
and Lake Worth so Trump is right that
it's potentially worth a lot of money uh
but judge Enron relied on the tax
assessor's value which put the market
value of maral Lago at between 18 and
27.6 million now that's probably on the
low end especially since tax assessor
valuations tend to be low but at the end
of the day the tax assessor's value is
still based on what Trump was telling
the local tax assessor the property was
worth and that's a number based on his
desire for low taxes and all the
incumbrances on the land and it sounds
like Trump knows he might not have a
legal right to build private residences
on the property but he leaves open the
possibility of negotiating different
restrictions with the National Trust he
can also argue that even with a deed
broad language there's still things that
he can do to develop the property that
would make the valuation higher but
Trump could also face opposition from
the US Treasury if the eement was
subject to an income tax deduction then
treasury regulation suggests that
easements must be perpetual and would
need to be extinguished by a court and
prosecutors confronted Trump with his
own comments about the 40 Wall Street
property which he valued at more than
half a billion dollars in 2009 Capital 1
expressed concerns about Trump's cash
flow the bank had lent him 160 million
and Trump was claiming that 40 Wall
Street was worth half a billion dollars
even though the building only produced
$9 million in Revenue that year
according to the attorney general
Capital One met with Trump and
Commercial Real Estate firm kushman in
Wakefield came in to assess the asset
determining it was worth 200 million as
of August 1st 2010 uh Trump however
insisted the building was worth much
more at least 600 million because it was
allegedly making around 50 to 60 million
per year Trump apparently made these
comments to a Forbes reporter on tape
but he told the court that he did not
recall making the statements where did
you do get that from well we're here to
listen to what you're you have
$64 million net net after Debt Service
this year at least in a 2022 article
Forbes reported that Trump admitted in
2015 to his own involvement in
bolstering his assets because a high net
worth is quote good for financing Trump
first denied telling forbs that he
needed a good net worth but then
admitted that having high net worth is
helpful for some kinds of financing 40
Wall Street apparently has never gotten
close to raking in 50 million per year
annual net operating income pequ at 20.7
million in 2018 and the attorney General
showed through Trump's testimony that
despite much lower and sometimes even
negative net revenue from leasing that
same building Trump used that $500
million valuation to get better loan
terms and Trump testified that the value
of his property 40 Wall Street is
hundreds of millions of dollars more
than what she says she doesn't even know
what 40 Wall Street is and that led to a
very testy lunch break uh during the
break the par has continued to squabble
and Trump made a truth social post uh
that only quoted part of the judge's
quote saying no I'm not here to hear
what president Trump has to say and then
left out the other part and all of the
context of that particular quote then
Attorney General James took to Twitter
to fire back at Trump's testimony that
she doesn't know what 40 Wall Street is
saying quote don't tell I can see it
from my office window and then Trump's
attorney Alina hoba spent her lunch
break explaining herself to an NBC News
correspondent quote when I followed up
on if she is urging Trump to answer more
concisely knowing Enron will be the one
delivering penalty stemming from the
suit Hava said that she would not tell
Trump that because she would not agree
to represent someone and then try to
limit their free speech and then habba
later stood outside the courtroom and
went into a full-on rant about the judge
he said judge Enron I turned red with
rage when Trump testified and accused
him of wanting to silence Trump then why
exactly am I being paid as an attorney
and why exactly are taxpayer dollars
being used in this courtroom you have a
right to hire a lawyer who can stand up
and say something when they see
something
wrong but I was told to sit down today I
was that and I've had a judge who is
unhinged slamming a table let me be very
clear I don't tolerate that in my life
I'm not going to tolerate it here and
you know what you shouldn't
either wow uh yeah so basically you can
tell that they know they are getting
absolutely screwed in the courtroom and
are trying to try their case in the
court of public opinion uh this is a
very unusual move sure to piss off the
judge and um yeah it just doesn't
recognize that judges have discretion to
run their courtrooms how they want and
as a lawyer usually you just have to
live with it they might be trying to
save some things for appeal but a lot of
the day-to-day stuff that happens inside
of a courtroom is unappealable and
they're just going to have to live with
it clearly they are trying to do some
stuff that is good for them in an
extrajudicial context uh but yeah things
are uh going from bad to worse inside of
the courtroom and then after lunch the
prosecutor questioned Trump about
several loan agreements with Deutsche
Bank uh when Trump developed the Old
Post Office property in Washington DC he
had to agree to certain representations
to get the loan he affirmed to the bank
that he had a minimum required cash
balance a minimum total net worth and
provided fair and accurate financial
statements for the current and prior
years the Attorney General is trying to
prove that Trump and his codefendants
deceive the bank to get favorable terms
and a lower interest rate and notably
Trump sold the Old Post Office lease
last year for $375 million and Trump was
expected to receive 126 million with
each of the adult kids expected to
receive roughly $4 million from the sale
Trump affirmed that the total proceeds
were $139 million and I'm sure the
Attorney General will argue that the
state should be allowed to claw back
those profits uh Trump argued that he
complied with the lending requirements
even though it doesn't look as if he was
really worth $2.5 billion as he alleged
uh quote the numbers are far greater
than the 2.5 billion therefore you have
no case now one of the covenants that
Trump affirmed to get the bank to lend
is that his statement of financial
condition condition are true and
accurate in all material respects
however when Assistant Attorney General
Wallace asked Trump about the EV
valuations of specific properties Trump
claimed that the documents included a
disclaimer that absolved him and the
company from liability for inaccuracies
quote the disclaimer Clause says if
there's a mistake if there's something
don't rely on it they always hold up in
court except maybe this court uh Trump
has been calling this a worthless Clause
but we have a clause in the contract
it's like a buyer beware Clause uh Trump
is referring to the disclaimers that his
accountants included on the statements
of financial condition the disclaimer
says that the statements were not
audited and the company can't say
whether the financial statements comply
with generally accepted accounting
principles uh but judge Enron as we've
talked about has already rejected this
argument in his pre-trial order quot
defendant Reliance on these quote
worthless disclaimers is worthless the
worthless Clause does not say what
defendants say it says does not rise to
the level of an enforcable disclaimer
and cannot be used to insulate fraud as
to facts particularly within defendants
knowledge even Vis A sophisticated
recipients and given this earlier ruling
judge anron wasn't willing to let Trump
testify repeatedly that the disclaimers
absolved him from liability and even if
this order did not already exist
Witnesses are there to testify about
facts and generally cannot testify to
their opinions about legal issues now
the Attorney General was arguing that
Trump was desperate to inflate his
personal wealth and that he told his
family and Company Executives to
manipulate the numbers when Trump was
asked about the valuations of specific
properties he insisted that some of the
numbers were inflated because property
values increase over time and in fact
discussing property valuations for 2014
Trump said quote if you carry that
forward to 2021 all of those valuations
were low so in Trump's mind if a
property was going to be worth more uh
almost a decade later he was justified
in simply adding that increased value
back in 2014 uh not surprisingly judge
anron previously rejected this argument
but then Trump testified that the
valuations weren't accurate anyway
because they didn't include his brand
value I.E the value that Trump
attributes to the Trump brand name uh AG
wall pounced on this response quote are
you testifying that these financial
statements are not accurate and then
Trump tried to walk back the response by
saying that they were accurate except
for the brand Value Plus the error he
made in the square footage of his
Penthouse plus an error in the
overvaluation of the Seven Springs uh
property so yeah lot of Errors now Trump
was also testifying that the banks
didn't care about his financial
statements and that the banks love Trump
because he helped them make money
however when Wallace showed Trump a loan
agreement he had signed with deut Bank
in 2012 Trump agreed that his financial
statements were intended to induce Banks
to lend money and that's a key element
of the Attorney General's fraud case
despite Trump's denial to the contrary
the statements were designed to get
favorable loan and insurance terms Trump
then launched into a monologue about
what his Bankers will say and stressing
that the financial statements were not
really documents that the banks paid
much attention to they looked at the
deal they looked at the asset if it is
real estate they looked at the location
though a retired Deutsche Bank official
had already testified that Trump's
financial statements were the Lynch pin
in his loan approvals uh she also said
that although the bank didn't do full
appraisals it sometimes gave haircuts to
Trump's valuations she said the bankers
called them quote sanity checks on
Trump's most outrageous numbers and
Trump testified that he relied on two
longtime Trump organization Executives
uh and an outside accounting firm to
prepare his financial statements he said
ex CFO Alan weiselberg would give him a
draft before each year statement was
finalized and that he quote look it over
and maybe have a suggestion but it
wasn't very important you've made it
important but it wasn't very important
to me and the Attorney General's office
asked Trump about the trust he
established to manage his assets before
he entered the White House they
established that Trump restored himself
as the sole trustee shortly before
Biden's inauguration but then gave up
control again in July of 2021 just days
after Alan weisselberg and the Trump
organization were indicted for tax fraud
at first Trump claimed that he made Don
Jr is trustee because he trusted his
business Acumen and was returning to
politics but on cross-examination Trump
agreed that he did so because of
increasing legal pressure quote you and
about other Democrat district attorney
Ag and US attorneys were coming at me
from 15 different sides all Democrats
Trump haters weiselberg pleaded guilty
to tax fraud and Wallace wanted to know
if uh this changed Trump's opinion of
wiberg's work for the company uh Trump
said yes that weiselberg was persecuted
by the state because of his relationship
with Trump and Trump admitted knowing
that the company was paying for wiberg's
apartment which was an issue in a tax
fraud case uh but Trump denied knowing
that weiselberg was reporting
transactions inaccurately in the books
and records of the company uh Trump says
that he learned that only in connection
with the tax fraud trial now what's
really interesting is that Trump's
testimony has been covered extensively
by more than 200 news outlets 32% of the
reporting is coming from the left and
26% is coming from the right and if you
compare the headlines you'll start to
see some interesting framing emerged on
the left you have Outlets using
terminology like temper tantrum and out
of control with reference to Trump's
disposition well on the right you'll
find Outlets using words like Tangles or
clashes and these word changes are
subtle but they play a big role in how
readers perceive the story the first set
of words might imply that Trump alone is
acting out while the second set of words
might imply that Trump is defending
himself against statements from the
judge now this is all possible thanks to
today's sponsor ground news a website
and app developed by a former NASA
engineer on a mission to give readers an
easy data- driven objective way to read
the news every story comes with a quick
visual breakdown of the political bias
factuality and ownership of the sources
reporting all backed by ratings from
three Independent News monitoring
organizations and I especially like the
new ground news comparison feature which
highlights specific differences between
the left and right reporter for stories
on Trump's testimony you can see that
left leaning Outlets tend to focus on
the trial itself and that judge angron
has stated he'll draw negative
inferences from Trump's testimony while
the right focuses on statements by Eric
Trump attacking New York and saying the
city is going to hell and ground news
also has a blind spot feed which
highlights stories that are
disproportionately covered by one side
of the political Spectrum this is so
important so we don't live in an echo
chamber or get misled by subtle and
sometimes not so subtle language in the
news so try out ground news by click on
the link that's on screen or down below
just for Black Friday starting now and
continuing through November 30 you can
get their biggest sale of the year right
now you can get a 40% discount on ground
NOS Advantage subscription their
subscription includes unlimited access
to all ground news features and with the
sale of the subscription is only $5 a
month it's the biggest deal of the year
so go to ground. news/ legal eagle or
click on the link below and you'll get a
40% discount to get unlimited access to
their app website and newsletter for
just $5 a month and after that click on
this link over here for more legal eagle
or I'll see you in court